(church bells ringing)
(slow piano music)
- I guess in this lifetime,
we weren't meant to be
yet the pictures
behind my eyeballs
are only you and me.
I only want to love you
and heaven knows I tried
so now the only way is suicide.
Then I'll fuck you in heaven,
that's when we can live in sin.
When the pearly gates are open
you can be inside me again.
- Yes I can be inside you again.
Hello.
- The first time I saw your face
I knew we were meant to be.
When I looked into your eyes
I thought, wow,
you're just like me.
- When I go to Jesus, you'll
go down on my all day.
- When I go to the
pie in the sky,
I'll lay there and
let you have your way.
And then I'll fuck
you in heaven,
that's when we can live in sin.
When the pearly gates are open,
you can be inside me again.
- Yes, I can be
inside you again.
If you can't have
me, no one else can.
- When we're dead, I'll
be your one and only man.
- Our timing was off.
- Our timing was bad.
- I blame my mom.
- And I blame my dad,
which is also your dad.
- And also your mom.
- [Both] And we'll fuck
all night in heaven
since we can't do
it here on Earth.
We're not allowed as lovers
even though we've been
together since birth.
Oh yes, together since birth.
I guess in this lifetime,
we weren't meant to be.
But when I kill myself, it
will finally be you and me.
Yes, finally just you and me.
- Mother?
(rap music)
♪ I want the money,
♪ I want the fame
♪ I want the whole
world to know my name ♪